people would be willing to do the grind
but they can't deal with the uncertainty
if you say hey hold your breath and the
person starts holding the breath it's
easy to do that if you know the person
is going to say you can breathe again in
10 seconds but if you just sit there and
you're like just staring at him I feel
like that's a lot of what the
entrepreneurship thing is it's like you
save up some money and then you take the
dive and you hold your breath and you're
like how long am I going to have to hold
my breath and the answer is you just
don't know and for me that was my big
fear I just didn't know how long it was
going to take I knew I wouldn't stop but
I know I was going to say